I am Nicoletta this is Matt Welch we're
doing ask a libertarian 2012 we're
celebrating the paperback release of the
Declaration of Independence later at the
month Matt here are your lightning round
questions David Woolley via Facebook
says or ask our Democratic measures such
as citizens initiatives and the right to
recall sufficient safeguards against
political corruption certainly not
sufficient but I like them I enjoy them
as a citizen of the West or at least a
born and raised in California it's a
great way to do things like put on the
ballot as we see this November in
Colorado in Washington full legalization
of marijuana or some initiatives that go
outside of the kind of partisan gridlock
and it's fun to recall corrupt and
incompetent governors like grey Davis
which is what my favorite activities in
the voting booth but it's not nearly
enough to tackle corruption Vakeel a
small and asked what do you think of the
Cass Sunstein nudge approach to Big
Brother dome Cass Sunstein Richard
Thaler wrote a book a few years back
called nudge which should have made the
case for libertarian paternalism if we
just tweak policies in ways that create
better kind of defaults towards people
that would make better choices we'll all
be better off I'm skeptical of it mostly
because of the design flaw of having
regulators create the perfect design I'm
just inherently skeptical of the ability
of the regulatory process to create
these kind of great choice architectures
for people Cass Sunstein's in the Obama
administration he's effectively his
regulatory czar and he's gotten some
good marks there although we haven't
really heard of a much about this kind
of nudge idea happening with the person
who's as responsible for that type of
governance as anyone ad via Twitter
Pietro PC ass
do you worry you're just trying to
signal something else pink Age pinkies
ass now that there's a tea party who
needs libertarianism the Tea Party does
among other things there's been a lot of
interesting conversations I think
between longtime libertarians and
ooh time Tea Party activists having
conversations hashing this stuff out
Rand Paul describes himself as basically
a tea party Republican even though he's
I think much more of a libertarian or
constitutional conservative it's an
ongoing discussion and I think
libertarians need to help that
discussion along I don't think the Tea
Party itself is composed of comprised of
libertarians but they have talked about
at least some fiscally libertarian goals
out there and so conversations need to
keep going Harvard asks why did most
reason author's vote for Obama and are
they smarter now the premise of your
question is inaccurate as far as I am
aware there are two current reasons
staffers who voted for Obama tim
cavanaugh freakin name and shame he
always discloses his ballot and Rahm
Bailey I should point out that most of
us I mean reason is one of the only
publications in the universe that asks
its staffers to disclose who votes we do
it's late does it and basically nobody
else does it that's two people out of a
staff of 18 or so last time around and
we published a interesting forum in 2010
asking people so do you who vote of
libertarians who voted for Obama do you
have any regrets what you have to say
about it and I recommend everyone go
look at look it up all right thank you
Matt ask a libertarian 2012 we're going
to be back with our final segment it's a
very special segment called what did we
learn today
[Music]